this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armies Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week after a lot of requests from You
Beautiful People Jonathan is taking a
look at the bombastic Weaponry of Deep
Rock Galactic did I just hear an AC DC
reference For Those About to Rock and
stone For Those About to Rock and stone
instant bonus points if that was an AC
DC reference rocking Stone forever if
you like this kind of content we've got
a brand new season of Loadout airing on
the channel right now new episodes will
launch every Sunday and you could
already check out our most recent
episode all about Gaming's tricky task
tackling the flamethrower right let's
take a look at the weapons of Deep Rock
galactic
like that
strange looking gun with a big cylinder
on the side I suppose the the thing that
sticks out to me is the stuff that's
bleeding through from tactical Shooters
there's a hint of a picatinny rail on
top there I don't know if that's
functional and there's also a very
strange Armature is that the right word
some sort of brackety thing that hangs
off the front of the magazine well not
doing very much not really sure what
that's for sort of a sort of a space
assault rifle really I would I would
summarize this in terms of what you
might call form factor and roll we've
got iron sights but embedded in that
what looks like a rail on the top they
look to be almost like two rear sights
that might be my screen they're very
chunky either way so there's a v-notch
in the rear it almost looks like another
v- notch on the front I might be wrong
about that now they would just about
work as sites they're very close
together that's a problem with Bullpup
rifles I'm not convinced this is of all
Pub it's just very short just has an
action that's closer to the to the grip
than normal I don't think it's behind it
yeah there's more to say about this than
you might think
[Music]
right so I think I understand the
fictional mechanism of this a little bit
better so that's heat shield portion of
the gun is is coming back from the
forward position there is an ejection
Port that is mostly exposed behind that
they look big enough for the for the at
least for the round to come out the case
to come out of problem with that if this
was real is that's coming back if not
instantly then pretty near instantly and
that's going to interfere with the case
ejection and prevent very likely Jam the
case on its way out or at the very least
interfere with it yeah it's not ideal
there's a reason why ejection Port
covers spring out the way and stay there
I don't think of a true ejection port
cover that
stays in place and flaps madly open and
closed which is effectively what this
does so not a sound mechanism if we're
trying to make this for real you'll be
disappointed here
okay dual wielded machine pistols
they're very slow for machine pistols
due to the small mass of their bolts or
slides my brain objects on principle to
the magazines being angled backwards but
there's something a bit unusual going on
with these because the muzzle flash is
blue which is sort of shorthand Force
Base gun I think we expect to see a
muzzle Clash of some sort and a way to
differentiate that from earth-based
Weaponry is to make it blue or green I'm
not seeing a button pressed or anything
but there's some clever magazine
ejection going on here generally
speaking not a great idea off the top of
my head there might well be something in
the way of the magazine that would stop
it from fully ejecting you you want to
remove a magazine under control does not
apply to games games love emergency
reloads and in this case we're getting a
dual one pressing some sort of button
and our magazines go flying it's almost
like a shotgun ejector which is actually
a spring-loaded device that kicks your
empty case or shell clearer of the gun
with quite a lot of force
foreign
[Music]
next up the Thunderhead heavy Auto
Cannon there's a combination here of low
poly but High detail or relatively High
detail kind of appeals to my Nostalgia
The Nostalgia center of my brain I
suspect and there's a lot of not only
detail in terms of some texturing
there's a lot of detail in terms of how
this weapon is constructed there are
even Little Wing nuts rendered in low
low poly graphics on the side of the
grip which is a sort of single Spade
grip if that makes sense because this is
a heavy gun almost motorcycle shock
absorber struts at the back which I
think are quite visually interesting
even if they might not do very much in
practice what almost looks like a an AK
safety selector on the right hand side
which is in the wrong place to do
anything actually and then the rounds in
front of the front of that are so huge
that I think that's just a control of
some sort we probably won't see it
operated in front of that we have big
old coil springs around the barrel you
don't see these on most don't see these
on Firearms you see them on light
weapons but heavy cannons and this says
heavy Auto
something like a 20 millimeter cannon so
the the olicon for example has a great
big coil spring around the barrel and
that's how it reasserts its barrels uh
back to the back to battery effectively
and then big cone flash hiders on the on
the front Barrels in other words an
awful lot of real firearm features or
real light weapon Cannon features
depending on what the caliber of this is
supposed to be and I don't think this
game gets into
named calibers
some gameplay footage and this thing
lives up to its name definitely inspired
by twin uh olicon or beaufort's
anti-aircraft guns on the deck of a ship
or something like that plugging away at
a low rate of fire with a very large
projectile designed to contain either a
very big armor penetrator or explosive
content or some other payload or
combination of those designed to put big
holes in aircraft or whatever you care
to shoot them at the round count is a
bit high for something of this nature
the gun itself would be astonishingly
heavy and big old 20 to 30 millimeter
rounds like that I guess I'll play
player character is smaller than the
average person so I probably should be
trying to scale things too much but
suffice to say these rounds are big they
are heavy and you're probably not going
to carry I think there's a hundred on
the gun and of course we have a we have
a reserve capacity in our black hole
ammo pouch oh another 660 rounds which
is a lot
[Music]
pretty typical sort of shotgun now
probably the first one I shotgun I've
seen with a round counter on it I mean
I'm not sure how bad at maths you need
to be to not be able to count to two
even I can manage that and I'm a museum
curator just an observation I suppose
the I think it's in it's quite
intriguing how the the sort of visual
language of the shotgun doesn't drift
too far from from the basic tropes the
the cartridge cases are chunky versions
of modern red plastic hold brass headed
shotgun cartridges shotgun shells
whatever you want to call them and it's
it's kind of amazing how many games
regardless of how far in the future or
how how sci-fi the setting is the
shotguns will typically feed
conventional ordinary shotgun shells
which are which go which date back to
the 1850s I think our brain has to play
catch-up if ammunition for a shotgun is
anything other than that even if they
change the color from red to something
else I think we subconsciously object is
my half-baked theory on that
I think this might be the most
interesting gun in the game because of
the parallel the obvious parallels
they're trying to draw with the M1
Garand it's even called the m1000 so
what are the similarities well that's
the main one we've got the Ping we've
got a version of the mechanism
it's not
bang on the Same by any means there's a
weird flip up bit of behind the breach
that I don't know what that's doing the
cocking handle folds in and out for no
obvious reason like it's locking
something in place that's that's
redundant we don't need that there's a
hint of
M1 other than the feet mechanism with
the open top and the closed bolt system
um with the drum of the wrist sight so
we have an iron sight aperture iron
sight that's with protectors and the
drums so that's all extrapolated from
the the rear sight on the real gun I
think it's pretty heavily extrapolated
from from mcgarren but you know the more
I look the more I see features we have
got the
a hint of the gas block at the front and
of the gas piston under the barrel which
is what drives this operating rod and
therefore the Bolt's back to do its job
so it's an M1 Garand in space inserts as
many A's in the word space as you wish
very quick word the the the
Garand I've chosen is our once converted
to fully automatic garage this is uh
what's what's often called the the YSL
or Yankee self-loader which is actually
an amusing nickname apologies to my
American friends nickname applied by the
British at the time
probably a bit jealous to be honest this
amazing weapon to all M1 garen's but
this one has the name has stuck because
it's specifically referenced in the
documentation under that nickname and
thanks to a valued new contact of ours
John Boland he has 3D printed for us the
missing parts for this that would allow
us in theory to uh make it fully
automatic again which is really exciting
and even if we were not shoot it we can
at least show the missing parts and we
can even install them
in the gun so I'm hoping to at the very
least um install the parts this is one
of them 3D printed in Steel
it's amazing I feel like I'm living in
the future thank you John
something I missed at first is we've
we've got a bit of a zoom in going on at
points and when the thing there's no
scope but it is your view is zooming in
and then the guns firing or rifle is
firing two shots at once so I don't know
if a bit like Half-Life maybe the thing
under the no I don't think there's I
think there's no hole in the what's what
should be the gas tube so I think it's
just somehow loading and firing two
around through the same Barrel which is
of course not a bit of a bit of a quirky
one even for
even for this gun
okay next gun I'm just looking at this
cold this says deep core 40 millimeter
pgl that tells me that's a grenade
launcher so we have a caliber mention of
course kind of looks like some sort of
gray launcher what all the pipes are all
over it I don't know I might be about to
find out double trigger guard now I've
criticized game guns for having two
pointless trigger guards before and then
someone made a real rifle that has
double redundant trigger guards that I
now can't remember which is really
annoying but someone did it
so I can't I shouldn't discount things
as something that wouldn't happen in
reality because
some people do stuff like that quite an
elaborate looking sighting system I
don't know I'm clearly not functional in
the game because there are no iron
sights functionality wise in the game
visually it's a hybrid of um grenade
launcher like the GM 94 or less so an
m79 and some sort of requireless weapon
or rocket launcher with that straight
through Tube without a buttstock on it
it's a little bit distinctive
[Music]
right another great big hit fired gun
here triple barreled with a racing
structure at the front which brings to
mind uh released a couple of these
triple barrel Gatling guns Gatling guns
famously sort of six to ten barrels but
um there are as few as three on some so
there's the the gow 19 sorry American
machine gun just a bit of Cam machine
gun but it has triple barrels to
increase rate of fire and deal with heat
which are the two main reasons you have
a gallon gun but I think this is pretty
far removed from its source material
um hey for all I know they came up with
the three Barrel gun independently of
the real ones that do exist I need a
rock in here
all right
quite a visually interesting take on a
on a minigun or a chain gun or a Gatling
gun whatever you want to call it I'm not
I don't remember seeing one with visible
turning Gear wheels the flat green arm
things that sort of lie flat when you
pull the trigger and then sort of sit at
a weird angle when you don't I have no
idea what those are doing it almost
settles into a slightly underwhelming
condition where it's just kind of
purring away but if you watch real
miniguns firing long bursts that's
that's kind of right they're very
impressive but at the same time they
just kind of sit there purring like a
very deadly
cat
all right so with when this thing
overheats as most high rated fire
machine guns and games maybe not most
but a lot do it does look like the at
least one of those stuck on things on on
this gun is doing something and that
thing appears to be being a heat sink
that's something that per se doesn't we
don't have on Firearms today but
conceivably we might have heat sinks or
guns that run at a very high rate and
are very big they're probably they would
probably be in place and I suspect it's
more likely there'd be some sort of
energy weapon but I'm speculating why
already that's that seems to be what
that cylinder on top of the gun is doing
it's not handling the Heat and trying to
cool the breaches of the gun down so
that it can resume firing safely of
course when real guns overheat they get
damaged and stop working
um they don't magically fix themselves
and carry on working again once you've
cooled them down
[Music]
we've seen quite a few pistols in games
over the years with this what
effectively amounts to a super short
barrel so designers want the magazine in
front of the pistol grip normally of
course pistols uh self-loading pistols
the magazine goes in the grip if we look
here at the depth of the magazine if
that makes sense the distance from the
front to the back of the magazine that
would dictate the length of the
cartridge which is already too long for
the ejection Port so you won't be able
to eject even an empty case let alone
the whole round if you were to chamber
that round into that incredibly short
barrel about half the round would be
sticking out the front of the gun
you're cute but you're dead
all right so for playing the game of
could you make this work it looks like
the the empty cartridge cases are just
the right size to come out of the
ejection report which makes sense from a
design point of view we would notice if
they were not going to physically you
know if they're going to clip through
the side of your model now the rounds
for this it's a complete round for this
have recessed bullet bullets recessed
into the case as was the case with the
Nagant Revolver that would be one way
around that and a way around the
Apparently super short and possibly
short barrel would be if what looks like
the bolt is actually telescoped around
the cartridge which means you would have
at least an inch or so of barrel to
actually spin your projectile so I think
I can fudge that to work
the bugs are swarming Loretta
all right we're into some real sci-fi
stuff here with this plasma weapon with
some attractive purple purple space
laser stuff going on weirdly enough
despite being the most sci-fi gun I've
seen so far it has several actual
Picatinny rails on it which the other
guns haven't had despite firing
conventional ammunition which is a
little bit weird I have to immediately
detract slightly from from the Sci-Fi
look of this gun which is actually
pretty creative and sci-fi looking but
as soon as you put present day
attachment systems on something little
part of my brain objects because I just
can't see that being the case
all right I've noticed a couple more
things so the picatinny rail is heavily
slanted downward which is a little
bizarre considering it has iron sights
mounted on it that you have to in theory
line up to shoot but you can't on this
unfortunately for the player there are
no iron sight there's no iron sight
aiming jokes
stylistic quibble that I would have
there it's been the rear sight's been
raised purely to allow you to have a
funky round counter as well although
this doesn't have conventional
ammunition clearly this is entirely heat
based and took me a while to Cotton on
here but there's a tiny little cooling
fan behind the round counter that to
reload or to sort of enable more rounds
to be fired be added back to the counter
effectively you sort of poke the fan I
just thought maybe detachable ejecting
heat sinks or something we've seen that
before might be a better way to go but
hey it's quite it's quite fun
foreign
big Magnum revolver of a type we've seen
many times this one probably more than
any I can think of looks a lot like the
Nerf Maverick due to the proportions and
the great big muzzle weight thing on the
end break open which is not a surprise
and the reload is a replaceable cylinder
which not very efficient because of
course you're Machining up a piece of
expensive complicated piece of metal
that's part of the gun making loads of
them and then using those as your feed
device this is why speed loaders exist
because that's not cost effective in any
way I mean I guess with with modern
future technology you could make
cylinders truly interchangeable drop in
drop out but traditionally revolvers
have to be sort of gunsmith to work
properly to be timed to to orientate the
cylinder precisely relative to the
barrel replaceable cylinders kind of
mess with that but but doable um it's
just wasteful especially considering
these guys are mining for resources
they're effectively
throwing away a lot of that
[Music]
on the face of it quite a conventional
shotgun albeit you're only pumping it
for the first round it's a self-loading
shotgun it's just that they've made the
cocking handle a pump grip for no clear
reason there is in fact a reciprocating
cocking handle on the left hand side
that would work just fine so I don't
know why there is a redundant means of
cocking it having said that the new Next
Generation Squad weapon rifle the the
newly renamed xm7 does in fact have two
cocking handles so yeah not not strictly
necessary it's it's the rule of cool I
think the advantage here is of a self
semi-automatic shotgun where you get the
cool pump action as well so that is
getting around from the drum magazine
into the breach weirdly enough the bolts
appears to be behind the magazine
doesn't make a great deal of sense uh
unless it's some sort of uh well that's
suppose the the Maxim machine gun sort
of works that way in that it pulls
around back without the belt and then
forward into the action but even then
there yeah it's not quite the same thing
so surprisingly there's actually a bit
to talk about on this
sticky and gooey
right that's pretty interesting to me
that seems like a sort of take on a
flamethrower in a weird sort of way
although it's firing or shooting it
should take not firing Blobs of acid goo
which look pretty cool and Fizz away on
contact with things it's sort of I think
filling the niche that would otherwise
be occupied by a painter so you get
you'd have a continuous burst but that
was my first impression obviously I
can't say much about how it's how it's
operating it's essentially a pressurized
tank of something we're recharging it
with some canisters and it's it has the
the other reason I mentioned
flamethrowers is it has the sort of
stick burn quality of a more realistic
take on a plane thrower even though this
thing is not at all realistic and he's
not
contradiction in terms here slightly we
have a something described as a smart
rifle so I assume the electronics are
not just decoration on this one I think
they're going to do something but the
contradiction is that it's called a
rifle but it's in a submachine gun class
if I understand this correctly and sure
enough that magazine is containing
pistol-sized conventional rounds with as
we've seen before in this game a weird
sort of bracket supporting the magazine
for no apparent reason unless that is
effectively your magazine catch have a
look
foreign
that's really cool that takes to sort of
lock-on Technology of a what is
fictional lock on technology of a
typical rocket launcher and applies it
to a submachine gun I suppose it's not a
million miles away from Game depictions
of the aliens smart gun but that will
that will only sort of lock onto or soft
lock or whatever onto one target at a
time all the versions I played to do
anyway whereas this is engaging multiple
targets and giving you visual indicators
of what it's locked onto and what's
going to get hit by bullets that's a
that's a really fun sci-fi take on a
guided weapon that's being enabled by
some sort of I thought it was a laser
but it's some kind of a sensor that sits
on top of the gun this is technology
that exists but not on rounds this small
so about 10 years ago now the American
DARPA organization released uh footage
of a steerable 50 caliber bullet that I
think worked using inflatable bladders
effectively on its surface that alter
the airflow and steered the bullet in
flight so the idea of steerable
projectiles is
plausible miniaturizing that technology
down to a pistol round I'm not sure that
would ever be possible or by the time we
could do that we could probably do
energy weapons for the portable
if you'd like to support us here at the
Royal armories I think you know the
drill by now head over to our website or
to our social media platforms we do have
um quite excitingly a real life event
which is the 11th of March we have a
date now I'm not quite sure when tickets
are going up for sale please do keep an
eye out again on the website our social
media Facebook Instagram Twitter and
we'll be doing a version of our what is
this weapon
um YouTube series but you know in a sort
of live setting hope to see you there
guys if not we'll see you again next
time
[Music]
foreign